California is failing very fast a state
where only illegal immigrants and
wealthy tech barons now feel welcome
with thousands living in close proximity
on Skid Row hygiene is always an issue
but with an official outbreak of
hepatitis A it's now a necessity heat
Steinle was fatally shot in 2015 by a
repeat felon and five-time deportee who
was shielded by the city's sanctuary
policy stench of urine and feces is
strong welcome to one of San Francisco's
newest tent cities authorities are
certain they would have arrested 800
more immigrants but Oakland's mayor
issued a statement over the weekend
warning of the raids California matters
it's our biggest date at the leading
edge of everything Victor Davis Hanson
is a lifelong resident of the state he's
a senior fellow at the Hoover
Institution he joins us tonight
miss Janssen thanks a lot for coming on
you described the economic distribution
of California recently as a medieval
what does that mean that means that
about 75 percent of geographical areas
inhabited by 25% of lower-income people
by and large and we have a coastal
corridor from San Diego to Berkeley
where we have Caltech and Stanford and
we have about three trillion dollars in
capitalized Silicon Valley companies and
this is where all the policy is made and
these people who make it the lawyers
academics politicians are never subject
to the ramifications of their own
ideologies because they have such wealth
and so California is a medieval Society
in the sense that we have the highest
basket of gasoline sales and income tax
but we ranked 45th in school test scores
49th according to Forbes and
infrastructure among the highest
kilowatt rates in the nation our
gasoline tax is going to be the highest
cost of gasoline is the highest but it
doesn't affect the people on the coast
who make these regulations I mean where
I work at Stanford at 70 degrees or 65
degrees I don't have to turn on the
air-conditioning or the heater but where
I live in the San Joaquin Valley poor
people have to go into Wall
because they can't afford to turn on
their air conditioner so people in this
medieval society on the coast they don't
believe in water transfers for
agriculture and for poor people but they
surely do for the artificial landscapes
in the Bay Area whether its Hetch Hetchy
or the California Water Project so that
attitude is it sort of reverberates
throughout California and it's a
dysfunctional state because of that
there's the middle class about four or
five million people have left we had
about four or five million people come
illegally from southern Mexico and we've
had a enormous concentration of global
wealth in a very small geographical area
and you put all that together and you
get what you have now it's unbelievable
they're running for their own benefit
picture Davis Hanson will the great
summaries of what's happening health
when I appreciate that thank you